this morning we're sharing a story about
the power of redemption and paying it
forward
the u.s has less than 5 percent of the
world's population but about
20 percent of its prison population that
is not good one california program
is tackling mass incarceration by
focusing on
empathy and restorative justice omar
villafranca shows us how an unlikely
partnership forged behind bars
helped a high school student in need and
it all began in a prison book club
it was incredibly refreshing to have
young men come
into a space with us and see us as what
we are
which is people for the past seven years
students from the palma school in
salinas california
have been part of a book club at an
unlikely place
soledad prison and former inmate jason
bryant says
the discussions went beyond plot lines
and protagonists
when i encountered the young men i was
just encouraged to see the the good
choices that they were making
at such a young age when i was not when
he was 20 years old
bryant was sentenced to 26 years to life
for his involvement in a 1999 robbery
that resulted in a shooting death behind
bars
bryant was looking for ways to be of
service
then at book club he heard about ernest
gordon's
miracle on the river kwai in the book
prisoners of war created a culture of
sacrifice
and they called it mucking for each
other inspired by the pows
bryant and his co-defendant hatched a
plan
and he leaned over and he said that is
exactly what we need to do we need to
muck for a young man
the brothers in bloom as they were
called decided to raise money
from other prisoners to create a
scholarship
fund for a palma student in need
almost 800 inmates many working jobs
like
sweeping clerking or making furniture
raised 32 thousand dollars over the
course of three years
so the base pay for incarcerated people
in the state of california is eight
cents an hour
an hour an hour and incarcerated people
were so drawn
to the idea of going a mile deep in a
young man's life
that they were giving up their month's
pay
to contribute they were anywhere from 50
cents to
a hundred dollars here and there mia
marasu and jim michaletti founded the
literature program
called exercises in empathy when
students go in justifiably they're a
little bit afraid they go in
thinking monster and they come out
thinking a man a human being
and they've done bad things but there's
no throwaway people here
when they learned about the inmates plan
they knew exactly
who should receive the scholarship
before his sophomore year
cy green's father had a heart transplant
his mother
had an accident and lost her vision and
both parents
lost their jobs that was a financial
burden
with all the medical bills and stuff
greene was shocked to learn
inmates who he'd never met had come
together to pay for his tuition
so he could continue going to private
school i was mind blown
and then immediately i was just grateful
greene is now 19
and in college he graduated from palma
school last year
with bryant by his side is there any
level of personal
redemption in getting involved in
something like this
i mean you're talking to someone who
committed a crime
that cannot be undone um
the harm so i don't know about
redemption
i can say this i know that those of us
who have truly transformed our lives
are committed to add value in any way
that we possibly can
after 20 years behind bars last march
california governor gavin newsom
granted bryant clemency backdrop
yeah i think so he's using his second
chance to mentor students like
cy greene who know he also has a
responsibility
to continue paying it forward and having
that
i guess them in the back of my mind all
the time they put all this effort and
all this work
into me so i have to honor that and
carry that legacy on
for cbs this morning omar villafranca
dallas
thank you omar villafranca dallas
there's so many layers to that story
it just kept getting deeper and deeper
it really did i left cy green saying he
was mind blown and then grateful
and then and the the other instructor
who said they're they've done bad things
but they're not bad people
and the lessons that have been learned
they're in everybody involved and you
realize with the prisoners who were
making eight cents an hour
how much work went into giving him that
i was trying to figure out the math and
i lost yeah i lost it i couldn't do it
and you give the money to a person you
don't know